Boo!
Rare MatPat jump scare. Hello internet.
Welcome to Film Theory where today I'm
going to tell you a ghost story.
So if you've ever watched even a
fraction of my stuff that I do online,
you'll know that I was a theater kid.
*Singing*
A big theater kid.
*More singing*
Like I said, just pure, unadulterated
theater trash. And it goes all the way
back to when I was in kindergarten.
For my first career day I actually
remember that I dressed up in a suit
and tie. Here was everyone else,
in their cute little firefighter hats or their
doctors coats or whatever. And here I was,
little mini MatPat, looking like the
world's teeniest, tiniest accountant.
When adults asked me what I was dressed
as, I would say "I'm an actor" because
apparently I thought actors wore the
fanciest, most nicest clothing out
there. How wrong I was. As most of you know
at this point, I went to college for a
combination of theater and neuroscience,
and while I was there, I tried to do
as many shows as humanly possible.
I played every role from a neurotic manservant to
a neurotic court jester to a neurotic Halloween
monster. In other words, I had range. That's
what they would call it in the business. But
there was this one semester where I don't
know, just everything that was being produced
looked boring. The musical was one I'd done
before, and the theater department show was
what theater department shows always are
at colleges: something esoteric and weird.
I am commenting on this couch.
I am commenting on the teeny cubby in this room.
This is what my character would choose. Also,
can I just say I love the full 360 tour that
you're getting of the GTLive studio right now?
Anyway, I loved all of this stuff. Like I
said, pure theater trash. And after all,
if I was going to be making a career
in theater, this is my job, right?
So I couldn't not be doing a show for a couple
of months. So I did what was probably the
unthinkable: I crossed enemy lines. I went
to audition at the rival school. Can we fire
up like a dramatic chipmunk? Or what's, what's a
good, relevant version of dramatic chipmunk these
days? It's not betrayal, but there's, like, this
one bit from Zoolander where... he turns around
and then Owen Wilson is, like, looking all
fabulous and it's like, who is she? Can I
just say this? I love that. I ask for a more
relevant example than the dramatic chipmunk.
And the response that I got back was Zoolander.
You know, that classic Ben Stiller movie that
predates all of this? Honestly, no one had ever
done that sort of thing before because I guess
no one had ever really thought about it like, Oh,
you could audition at the rival school in the way.
Well, I did. And I don't know if I can truly
impress upon you how big of a thing this was,
because I went to Duke and it has
like one of the all time most intense
rivalries against the neighboring
school... United Church of Christ.
Not the United Church of Christ, the
University of North Carolina or UNC
for short. And let me tell you, I pulled out
all the stops for this audition. In general,
my auditions tended to be unique
*singing* For this one in particular,
I wanted to make a big impression to the
other school. So I went in and I did a
dramatic monologue of "Bet on It" from
High School Musical 2. In case you've
repressed your memories over that Disney
original production, here's the refresher:
*singing* "to see yourself
and not recognize your face. Out on my own..."
Ah just look at that Disney Channel original movie
level water reflection right there. And you heard
me right. I didn't sing the song. I said it
as a monologue, not singing. The struggles
of being Troy Bolton forced onto a golf course.
Here, let me see if I can pull up a moment here.
Everybody's always talking at me.
Everybody's trying to get in my head.
I've got to listen to my own heart talking.
I've got to listen to myself instead. Bet on
it. Bet on it. Bet on it. Bet on me. Long story
short, I clearly got the part. The show, oh,
was this crazy show called Urinetown Town? Which
if you haven't heard of it, I'm not surprised.
It's not super popular with a name like Urinetown
town. It's actually a joke that they write into
the musical. But it's about this world where you
have to pay to pee because they've run out of
water. You know? Theater shows gonna theater. You
know what I'm saying? Anyway, it was while I was
being a turncoat at UNC that I met this girl
named Haley, who is a UNC alum who, inspired
by my galaxy-brained maneuvering here, actually
crossed back over to my school, Duke to audition.
And unlike me, Haley was actually good, like
legitimately very good. Like good enough to
perform in front of the entirety of a packed
a Yankees baseball stadium. Roll the clip.
*Singing God Bless America*
Legit, right? Just casually
dropping the high notes in front of
46,000 sports fans. Sure.
Way to show off there, honey.
Anyway, Haley and I bonded over the
fact that we were the defectors,
the ones that were willing to cross enemy
lines, as it were. We were casual friends all
throughout the rest of college. We graduate, life
happens. Everyone moves on. You know how it goes.
I become that big nerd guy over on YouTube. That
part you're probably a bit more familiar with.
But then, out of nowhere, at the top of this
year, I see a familiar name pop up in my inbox.
It's Haley. Dear Matt. Hello there. It's been
too long. I am now the mother of a six year
old. Time happens fast. And my stepson, who is
a budding video game composer, he's amazing.
And his favorite show to watch online, much to my
surprise, an old familiar voice from college, you.
Pretty cool. We watch you every week. I don't
always understand it all. You and me both. But
you've made a huge difference in his life. Thank
you. I'm saying all of this not to humblebrag,
about like, woah, look at how important I was
to her son's childhood, but rather for the
context of what comes next. So this is completely
random, but I'm producing shows on Broadway now.
You know, just casual drop. I'm just a big time
Broadway producer, whatever. And the latest
project to come across my desk is Grey House, a
psychological thriller slash horror play coming to
Broadway this May. And I thought of you and Steph
immediately for this. After years of watching you,
I just feel like this would be such a fit
because it combines horror, mystery and theater,
and it would be introducing a brand new
genre to Broadway, which it's so craving.
Let me know if you'd like to get on the phone,
blah, blah, blah, etc. etc. It's definitely a
different email than I was expecting there,
but long story short, we said yes to meeting
with Haley and honestly, that's how we learned
about what the show was, which is really cool.
A couple gets into a car crash during a blizzard
up in the mountains and winds up trapped in this
mysterious cabin inhabited by a group of strange
girls who, get this, may or may not be dead.
Mm hmm. A lot of alarm bells
ringing, a lot of theorist
checkpoints there. There's
this strange glowing that's
coming from the basement. There are pentagrams
carved into the floor. There are monsters
literally crawling out of the walls and
throughout the whole thing you have
hidden messages sprinkled throughout,
hidden in stuff like Morse code and sign
language. I mean, put your jazz hands away,
ladies and gentlemen. Hamilton, this
is not. And the whole thing Anna Caruso
from Beetlejuice, Tatiana Maslany from She-Hulk,
and Millicent Simmonds from a Quiet Place. And
the whole thing is being directed by
the director who did Wicked. Like,
it is a stacked creative team.
But let's be honest, none of that mattered;
they had me the second they said dead kids.
So we said yes to investing in Grey House.
Now, normally what that would mean is that
you just write a check. That's all it is.
You literally are just helping to support
the arts with a bunch of other people
because creating theater in New York
is expensive. But hey, if the show goes
well, you get some of that money back.
Awesome. But surprising literally no
one, Steph and I weren't just content to
leave it alone. You guys know that
we are type-A personalities. Well,
I'd go so far as to say we are type A+
personalities, because if we're doing a thing,
then we are doing it, doing it. So,
Steph and I are all like, hey, you know,
we have 12 plus years of experience solving
spooky mysteries and horror things online.
I think there's a little bit more that
we could do to help the production. Since
this is a horror and mystery show, maybe, I
don't know, have you thought about doing some
dances over on TikTok or maybe an influencer
night? How about an ARG? Let me sit you down
and talk to you about how Jimmy Neutron
crosses over into the GrubHub universe.
They were a bit confused, and so we met
more and more of the marketing team and
the creative teams that were putting thi show
on. And we had some calls that were full of
some of the biggest names in the theater world.
And let me tell you, at first those calls were
I mean, I gotta be frank...
they were uncomfortable.
Let me explain why. You see, we have, like I
said, been doing this for 12 years. We know
this world. If I tell the editors to do this
right, you know exactly what this means. You
know what we're referencing.
Or something even more obscure:
if we do this. Or most obscure of all: this.
We all are chronically online. So we
know "da wey" and we also know why we
probably shouldn't be talking about "da wey"
anymore. But to the outside theater world,
oh boy, this whole thing? This is a big old black
box. Actually, it is worse than a black box.
This right here, this digital video land. it is
the home of Broadway's most dreaded two words:
slime tutorials. And we're not talking about
literal slime tutorials where we're making things
for kids. No, my friends, theater has to be
really restrictive when it comes to filming
shows because of all the copyrights and
union rules and performances involved.
Each show is allowed to just be filmed
once and only once for archival purposes.
That copy is then stored in one very specific
library in a corner of New York. But don't think
that you can just roll in and start watching
the original cast of Beetlejuice on repeat. No,
you absolutely can't. You can only watch that
tape recording one time in your entire life
and only if you can prove
they have a research-based
reason to watch it in the first place.
So in a world where we are literally dripping
in an excess of content, let's just say that
theater has itself a bit of an accessibility
problem. And as you see with any business,
a problem of accessibility ultimately gives
rise to piracy or in this case, slime tutorials,
the secret coded word for any bootlegged video
recording of a Broadway show. In a world where
people want to see theater but just can't because
of all the restrictive nature around it or the
high price point, slime tutorials have basically
stepped in here on YouTube to fill in the gap.
Most of them are really terrible quality. They
are definitely illegal, but if you really want
to see a show and you just can't afford
to or you can't make it to the theater
while it's performing, well, that's what
a lot of people have turned to. And to the
people in the theater world who don't
understand our corner of the Internet,
that right there, that is what digital video is.
And so here we are starting to roll into producer
meetings, me and Steph, Mr. and Mrs. Internet
video asking, "Hey guys, have you ever thought
about opening your doors and considering letting
theater influencers film bits of the rehearsals or
maybe get shots of the set being constructed?
Bring them along for the journey of the show?"
It got awkward fast. To them that was just
letting the slime flow forth. And it didn't help
either that theater is literally one of the
oldest art forms in the world. And Broadway, it
is like the most entrenched of institutions
that involve thousands of people to put on
these products. But the coolest thing about the
process here was that, at the end of the day,
even though they were nervous and they were
definitely uncertain about some of the stuff
that we were talking about, they said yes. At
least they kept an open mind to learning more.
They wanted to be educated. And bit by
bit, we watched as the walls began to
erode between these two worlds. There
starting to be more conversation. We
started to have more of the same language.
Yes to a YouTube strategy. Yes to doing
weird stunts like having creepy demon
girls wandering around Times Square
lurking in the backgrounds of people's tourist
photos to help promote this thing virally.
Yes to an influencer night. Can you
believe that? This was one of the first
shows on Broadway, if not the first show to
invite online creators to a preview event?
Film studios have been doing that for a
long time at this point; but, theater,
this was like mind blowing to them. And
let me tell you: the mood was electric.
People there were so excited to be a part
of this launch event. I finally got the
chance to meet with Thomas Sanders, who
I've been wanting to meet for years. But
we're always just like ships passing
in the night. As well as Ranboo, who,
you know, we cover a fair bit
across the channels. There was
also Gamer from Mars, Wait in the Wings, Swell
Entertainment. All people that I love to watch.
"I was sent an email saying that I was
invited to Great House on Broadway May 10th,
and I immediately was like, What?
So I know what you're thinking,
Amanda. Why you? I don't know. I still don't
know." I do, Amanda. It was us. It was us and
the creative team being fans of your work
and wanting you to be a part of this thing.
And now it's been done. Right? Creators
and Broadway have finally crossed over and,
hopefully, now that it's been done, once it's
easier to happen again and again and again. And
we're already starting to see that happen.
A week after we did that influencer night,
the main creative team asked Steph and I if
it was a good idea for them to start their own
subreddit so people could discuss the lore
of the show and solve it together online.
And we're like, yes, absolutely that's a
great idea. Also, you used the word subreddit,
right! A week ago that wouldn't have
been the case. They were like, "hey,
do you think it would be a good idea if we
started to give away free tickets? Would
people like that?" And we're like, duh!
Of course! Who wouldn't want that sort of thing,
guys. It's not rocket science. You know, when I
started doing theories ten, twelve years ago -
ancient, I'm literally dust - I was living in
New York, right? I was on those streets. I was
pounding the pavement in the theater district.
The show opened, what, like two or three blocks
away from where I would wake up every morning
and get there at 4 a.m. to stand in line for
them to finally open the door at 6 a.m. so I
could wait all day to try to get an audition
that never happened. This was a time
in my life where splitting a Chipotle
burrito was the big meal of the week
because it was what Steph and I could
afford based off of the budget that
we had at the time. And now here we
are trying to help shape this industry
that was so pivotal to my early life.
We're trying to update it. We're trying to
make it exciting and alive for a brand new
generation of artists and fans. And that's it's
kind of unreal. I let you guys know over on Game
Theory that I was going to be there for the
opening week of the show. And because this is
a show with mysterious lore that you just want
to discuss with your friends in order to solve,
we even did a talkback with all you theorists in
the audience. And while I've done just so many,
too many to count when it comes to talkbacks
and presentations and on stage performances and
whatever, this one was special. I mean,
this was on a Broadway stage. I mean,
it's not an exaggeration to say
like this was literally kindergarten
MatPat's dream come true.
Look, there it is: my bio in a Broadway
program. And I'm going to flashit
up on screen real quick for you to read.
There's an ARG in there. We're like, well,
if we're in a Broadway theater, like might as
well throw in an ARG mystery for you to solve.
That alone would have made it enough.
Like, wow, this is incredible. I get
to stand on a Broadway stage and talk. Like
that was awesome. But then you guys showed up.
And let me say that the theater was packed. And
the conversations that we had about the show,
it was it was incredible. You guys are amazing.
Your theories about the show were wonderful.
We even got to throw in a Five Nights at Freddy's
reference. It's the best jump scare ever. Eat
your heart out, Five Nights at Freddy's.
Five Nights at Freddy's on Broadway. Never
thought that crossover was going to happen,
but that is now on the 2023 bingo card.
If you want to see actually the full
Talkback that we did, it is here on YouTube.
I'll link to it and all the usual places.
The show wasn't done when the theater
closed. As we left there were just so many
of you out on the street, a group of people
so big that without exaggeration, they had to
shut the street down in front of the theater.
I mean, that right there, that was
incredible. We didn't get to actually
go to the afterparty celebrating the show
until hours after everyone else was there
because we were trying to spend as much
time as possible talking to you guys.
I was told by one of the producers on the
show that this is the sort of thing that
doesn't tend to happen on Broadway. But
you guys, you made it happen. The reason
I'm telling the story now is because it's
time for the production to wrap up. We're
revving up for the final performances.
We're getting ready to close the doors.
So now felt like the perfect time to
actually just tell you this story,
one that has just been a tremendous personal
achievement for me and a testament to everything
that we as a collective theorist community
have been able to do together. So if you
do want to be a part of that history and
see how the show comes together before all
record of it gets relegated to a random New
York library in the corner, grab a ticket
now, my friends. Link is in the description.
In fact, if you use the code GHTHEORIST,
you can save ten bucks on your tickets. Not only
is the show awesome, it's mysterious, it's scary,
it's thought provoking, but also it takes place
in a haunted theater. Nothing to see there, just
a ghost. Oh, it's a pipe.. And while I could
certainly just end the video right here now,
hey, that's a theory of film theory. But it
wasn't. Bah bah bah. I do want to leave you
with one last thing. You see this show, also an
incredible showcase for both hearing and non-
hearing actors using sign language all throughout
the presentation. And through this process, I was
actually fortunate enough to speak to the director
of artistic sign language, Andrew Merrill,
who spoke to us about the evolution of sign
language and how it's used throughout this show.
It's long, but it is a fascinating clip, which
is why I wanted to share it with you here right
at the end. So enjoy that as I leave you
here. And as always, my friends remember,
it's just a theory, a Film Theory. and scene.
You mentioned setting and taking into account
setting. Do different settings come with
different considerations when teaching things
around sign language or creating the language
of the world that you're putting up on stage?
Yeah, absolutely. So Grey House is set in the
'70s. We signed differently
in the '70s than we do now.
So we have to figure out exactly how to represent
that way we signed in the '70s in this show.
So we have a deaf character in the
show and we have some ASL in the show;
but, that's just one part of the story.
It's not the feature part of the story. It's just
that one of the characters happens to be deaf in
this world. We don't want the sign language to
essentially pull focus on the story. It's just
that we have a deaf character in the story. Could
you give us an example of something that would be
different today than it was in the '70s,
just so we could get a visual cue of that?
Sure, yes. So ASL, we don't have so much
documentation of the actual language because
there's no written form of ASL, whereas with
English we can see how it's changed from
Shakespearean times up until modern times.
But we didn't have the technology in the
'60s and '70s to fully document our language
and kind of codify it for the masses.
But I will give you a simple example. So
in the '70s we used to sign in English word
order rather than in our American Sign Language
grammar. Let's take the example, the sentence.
"who are you?" Today we would sign it like
this, "who are you?" In the '70s we would sign
"Who. Are. You? So these are little nuances.
They might not seem like a lot to you, but
definitely the deaf audience that comes to
see our show will be able to appreciate
and take in those nuances. Are there any
techniques that you use to help the actors
learn sign sign language faste? Or how does
that teaching process develop? We usually
have ASL sessions built into the rehearsal.
I'll talk with the actor about their
character or what they think works for
their character or why are you signing in
that moment or why are you not signing in
that moment? And then I get into the text and
start teaching them the translations. I record
myself with those translations and send
it to them so they can work on their own.
I have to say that this cast has been
phenomenal with learning sign language.
They're all such quick studies; they
learn so much in such a short amount
of time. We have such an amazing
cast, so grateful for all of them.